Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up, Prof? How you doing, Martin?
Walter, I'm doing very well, and you?
I'm also doing okay, thank you. That's
good. There's a lot of things happening
in the world quite quickly.
Yes, we were
discussing final events and how they are
unfolding in the world.
So, let's keep along this track for a
little while and have a look at current
events and
uh possible occurrences in the world
and see where we are in the stream of
time. Yes. So, let's open with a word of
prayer.
Our Father in heaven, it is a pleasure
to be working for you, and we thank you
there.
We also ask that you guide our
discussion and enlighten our minds with
the Holy Spirit, and we ask that in
Jesus name. Amen. Amen.
Now, we know that the Bible speaks about
food insecurity in the last days.
But, we must never neglect the promise,
your bread and water will be sure. So,
this is not fear-mongering.
This is putting events into perspective.
So, you've titled this one food
controlling the nations of the world.
We all know that it is a common saying
that he who controls the food supply
controls the world. Mhm.
Here we have an episode of from February
2016,
a program called The X Files. Martin,
run us through here. Well, the in this
episode was quite interesting is they
give us a breakdown
of what's happening in the world
currently. Uh-huh. So, it's interesting
while watching through this as this is
going to be a building block for what
the rest of the discussion is going to
be on. All right. So, many of these
things are predictive because
uh
if you want to be conspiratorial, there
are insiders in the know and they build
these things in. Secret societies always
want to display everything in plain
sight Yes. Yeah.
and think that the the [__] is in any
case too ignorant to unravel it. And the
thing is, they are clever because if you
desensitize someone
through the media or movies, then once
it happen
happens, they're not as shocked. Yes.
Now, I was just reading in the Spirit of
Prophecy
uh yesterday, as a matter of fact,
the last chapter in one of the Testimony
books,
and it's about the effect of theater.
What a tremendous effect it has on the
mind
and how it can influence you without you
even knowing. And uh of course, the
master strategist behind all of these
things is fully aware because he's made
a thorough study of the human psyche.
We we know that even subliminals that
you cannot see affect you. Oh, yes.
Tremendously. So, let's have a look at
what what they had to say in 2016.
has been making claims.
Claims about what?
You and everyone you know has a piece of
DNA in your genome put there without
your knowing it.
Put there by whom? Well, that's the
question of the day.
This is an internet lunatic. You're not
saying you believe him.
Hold on, Agent Einstein. You're talking
to a scientist. Uh forgive me, Assistant
Director. It may sound insensitive, but
the suggestion is pure science fiction.
What I'm saying, Agent Einstein, is that
the facts, as I understand them, cannot
be discounted out of hand.
No one has the right or the ability to
tamper with your DNA.
Unless we gave them that ability.
Are you saying they're tampering with
our DNA, that they're able to shut down
our immune systems by the addition of
something to our DNA? Yes, but I don't
know how exactly. But how it's being
triggered. I don't know that either.
So, why it's happening now.
What can we possibly do? We need to act
quickly. You're right about that.
Well, I was wrong about the science. I
was wrong about what's causing it. Dead
wrong, in fact. But it's clearly a
widespread failure of our immune
systems. Through gene tampering.
A virus within a virus that was put
there through the smallpox vaccine. It's
what these men are calling the Spartan
virus.
We have to figure this out.
What's wrong with the science?
Okay.
The Spartan virus removes the adenosine
deaminase gene from your DNA. Remove the
ADA gene and your immune system will
simply vanish. Yeah, but I'm not getting
sick.
It's only a matter of time.
Okay.
So, how does it work?
How does the virus remove the ADA gene?
A process called CRISPR Cas9.
Uh RNA and a protein cutting genes at
exact locations.
Exactly, but in this instance, used as a
weapon.
The ultimate weapon.
The ability to depopulate the planet.
To kill everyone but the chosen. By
tampering with their DNA.
Through gene editing. Why do such a
thing and lie about it? Your own
government.
Your own government lies as a matter of
course, as a matter of policy. The
Tuskegee experiments on black men in the
'30s, Henrietta Lacks.
What are they trying to do? That's the
missing piece. But it's not hard to
imagine a government hiding, hoarding
technology for 70 years at the expense
of human life and the future of the
planet.
Driven not only by corporate greed, but
a darker objective. The takeover of
America.
And then the world itself by any means
necessary, however violent
or cruel
or efficient.
By severe drought brought on by weather
wars conducted secretly using aerial
contaminants and high-altitude
electromagnetic waves in a state of
perpetual war
to create problem-reaction-solution
scenarios to distract, enrage, and
enslave American citizens at home.
With tools like the Patriot Act and the
National Defense Authorization Act,
which abridge the Constitution in the
name of national security.
The militarization of police forces in
cities across the US, the building of
prison camps by the Federal Emergency
Management Agency with no stated
purpose. The corporate takeover of food
and agriculture, pharmaceuticals and
health care, even the military and
clandestine agendas to fatten, dull,
sicken, and control a populace already
consumed by consumerism. And I encourage
you all to go shopping more. A
government that taps your phone,
collects your data, and monitors your
whereabouts with impunity.
A government preparing to use that data
against you when it strikes
and the final takeover begins.
The takeover of America. By a well-oiled
and well-armed multinational group of
elites that will cull, kill, and
subjugate.
Happening as we sit here. It's happening
all around us. The other shoe waiting to
drop. It'll probably start on a Friday.
The banks will announce a security
action necessitating their computers to
go offline all weekend. Digital money
will disappear. They can just steal your
money?
Followed by the detonation of strategic
electromagnetic pulse bombs to knock out
major grids.
What will seem like an attack on America
by terrorists or Russia.
An invasion of the US. The Russians
tried in '47.
Well, Martin, I don't think we put that
in there because
as prime conspiracy theorists, we
believe everything that it says, right?
Yeah.
The important thing is
not whether it is true
or whether it is not true.
To me, it is important
that the people
believe that it is true.
Even though it might not be true. Or it
might be true.
You see, it's one of those Hegelian
situations. Again, they tell you who the
perpetrators are.
They tell you it is the elites.
But they don't define the elites. No.
Now, in our last program,
we showed that the world generally feels
that the elites are the
multi-billionaire moguls. That's it.
Everybody is
investigating and then just coming to
this level.
Yes. Now, if they stay at that level,
then they have created in the minds of
men a common enemy. Mhm.
But what if that common enemy is not the
enemy? What if there is someone else
that is the enemy?
Now, in order to make it believable,
could you create the scenario
that makes it believable? Yes. Could you
bring about the pandemic? Yes. Could you
bring about uh inoculation as they are
speaking about?
Is it possible to manipulate the DNA? Is
it possible to reduce the immune system?
Is it possible to create so much chaos
and the gun chaos as we are seeing in
the world today? Mhm. Now, Martin, how
many years have we passed by since this
was made? 6 years.
Okay.
And if you put in place what has
happened in those 6 years, I mean, the
last 3 years,
won't many, many people on the planet be
convinced that this is what is really
unfolding? Yes. They will, right? Mhm.
Okay.
Is it expedient for someone behind the
scenes
for this to happen?
Yes, if he is behind the smoke screen.
And nobody sees him. Mhm.
And so the whole world becomes hyped up
in this.
And you get hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of videos daily
uh
entrenching these ideas in your mind.
Then the enemy
becomes a universal enemy. And there's a
major uprising. Did you hear about
depopulation in this study?
Yes. Now, isn't it interesting that the
Georgia Guidestones were just destroyed?
Yeah. By an explosion. Mhm. Exactly. And
then the rest of it was taken down with
a bulldozer. Mhm.
So, what are they rebelling against? Or
let's ask another question. Is this
something like a QAnon conspiracy
indicating that we're going to take down
these moguls?
Or is it perhaps the perpetrators
themselves who have done this in order
to create the idea that we're going to
take them down? That there will be a
kind of QAnon, whatever you want to call
it,
clean-up operation of the world. Mhm.
You see, that's exactly. So, that's even
a greater deception.
You create the hype that shifts the
blame
to somebody else. Yes.
And yeah, this whole thing, I don't
think it's far-fetched.
All right. Is it then possible, as we
have said before,
that the puppeteer
sitting behind the scenes is laughing
his head off because everything is going
according to plan? Exactly. If you take
what they showed in the previous episode
about Twitter and Musk,
on the one hand, he's saying this, but
on the other one, he's doing this.
All right. The other point was, this is
an attack against America.
Correct? Yeah. All right. Uh an attack
by whom?
By the ultra-liberal
controllers who are
uh narcissists and want to take over the
world, right? According to them, yes.
According to them.
And the world loves the story.
And
the more you make something secret, the
more you make it prominent.
That's just the way the human psyche
works.
So, let's just make it quite plain to
those who want to put us into the
category of conspiracy theorists. This
is not a theory because this is being
enacted on the world stage, whether in
reality or in fake, is irrelevant.
That's it. We're not interested in any
of this. We're not jumping on any of
these conspiracy theories. We are asking
a question.
Where is it heading? That's it. What is
it achieving?
Who's going to be happy about it? And
who is manipulating it and controlling
it? Or is it just random chaos that has
broken out in the world? Is Satan that
stupid?
No, he is organized. Huh? He is
organized. Have Have you uh seen that
series I did a couple of years ago
called Creta Malta? Yes. With the art of
war. That's it. How you do things.
Chung, chung. Yeah. Absolute control.
Mhm.
When you hear the sound of the drum,
boom. When you hear the sound of the
drum, boom. If you don't do exactly like
that, off goes your head, right?
All right. So, let's use that as a
setting.
So, here we have events in the world
which are running according to a plot
which has been broadcast and made
prominent in the media and through
movies and through series like The
X-Files, etc.
Uh substantiated here and there by those
who love this kind of thing in The
Simpsons and the You name it. Every
single possible and, of course, Walt
Disney movies and Hollywood-style Jesuit
theater.
So, that's what they want you to
believe.
Where is it heading? This is an attack
on America.
Now, what does America stand for?
Values, constitution,
freedom of religion.
What is under attack? Religion is under
attack. Is this a possibility
that they will move this whole scenario
to the point where they now are ready to
go onto the barricades,
get rid of all of this king of the south
attitude,
and enthrone the king of the north?
And the puppeteer
laughs.
He has succeeded
without being the object of suspicion
for a single second. And
on the contrary,
being the hero.
It turns out to be the hero and the
savior. Mhm. Martin,
uh is that what we call deception?
Definitely. Is that something that could
be in harmony with what the Bible says?
That's exactly what the Bible says. All
right. So, now people must be put into
straight places.
Because when it starts touching your
personal life, when your life is somehow
threatened,
then you have to become very circumspect
and decide, well, why is it like that?
Is it perhaps
uh God is unhappy with the godless state
of the world and is about to
interfere and therefore we have to set
matters straight.
Now, according to my scriptures,
matters are not going to be set
straight, they're going to become worse
because that will be the ultimate
deception. That's it. But it's going to
go there. It is.
Nothing's going to stop it. Nothing.
They're going to think, and that's
another thing. When all of this, like
the Georgia Guidestones, is getting rid
of and they and they arrest some of
these elites or all of this, they'll be
thinking, "Woo, now we're winning." Yes.
This was all This is also part of the
whole plan because you have must see
who's going to be the victor in the end.
Yes. And is it true that in the last few
months and years that we've had some
mega elites
embroiled in all kinds of debacles?
Like the Epstein saga, where even the
royals are involved and all of these
things. And people are looking, but
they're looking in the wrong place.
And they're just giving you a cherry
here and a cherry there.
There's nothing big.
No.
If you take this
uh this social media
year or two back,
they were in
front of the Senate the whole time. Yes.
Have you seen any difference in their
censoring? No. Well, let's put it this
way. If they want to condemn a certain
side, there is a huge media hype. And if
they are on the side of current
perpetrators, there is a suppression of
information.
So, once again, it shows it depends on
who's running the show.
Uh they're running both sides. That's
the point. And that is why
the conspiracy theory that we are
involved with is not the conspiracy
theory that you see in the common thread
in the media.
The conspiracy we are involved with is
the conspiracy that is outlined in this
book.
And where Isaiah speaks about
a confederacy. That's it. All right. So,
let's have a look at this article, which
is very interesting. New controlled food
system is now in place.
Who controls the food supply controls
the people. Who controls the energy can
control whole continents.
Are we dealing with food issues and
energy issues at the moment?
All right.
Who controls money can control the
world. This famous quote by Henry
Kissinger is ringing more and more true
by the week.
If they control the seeds, they control
the food.
And if they control the food, they can
use the digital ID to control consumer
access to the food.
Does the Bible speak about controlling
what you buy and how you buy it? Yep.
Okay.
While a rash of fires suddenly destroy
food processing. Now, Martin,
if they are painting a picture that they
want people to believe,
and sooner or later there must be a
savior that throws this terrible
calamity overboard,
and the hero must be the puppeteer.
Right? Then we have a script here, which
is
perfect.
So, a rash of fires suddenly destroyed
food processing, meat, and fertilizer
plants during a time where farmers are
hurting and supply chain issues are
kicking in, an entire traceable food
infrastructure system has already been
built in multiple cities,
and is making its way across the globe.
It's interesting, they have built
facilities
which are ultra-modern,
which are controlled by AI, where they
will process anything from cattle to
plant-based foods,
and none of it is in use yet. It is
being prepared for a future scenario.
And this is exactly where we're heading.
Yes. Uh we also had movies about that,
Soylent Green for example.
That is what is happening.
And it's not all going vegetarian as
they claim, because some of these
facilities that they're building in the
United States now
are meat processing plants,
where they will by AI technology use
every morsel of an animal.
Up to 80,000 animals can be processed
per day.
And it's only to come online in 2026.
The indoor indoor vertical farming
industry was valued at 5.5 billion in
2020,
and is projected to reach 19.86
billion by 2026.
For perspective, Bowery Farming's new
facility in Arlington
will be able to serve 16 million people
in a 200-mile radius. This is only one
of the dozens of vertical farming
companies with massive facilities across
the country,
backed by big investors. By the way, who
owns most of the farmland now?
Well, Bill Gates is own is the biggest
private farm owner in the in America.
Yes.
AeroFarms, who has the largest indoor
vertical
farming facility in the world,
co-developed the first CRISPR Cas9
gene-edited produce product.
Now, hundreds are following, while
National Geographic believes that gene
editing is the next food revolution.
Martin, what did they say in those
X-Files? Yeah, isn't it interesting? The
bioweapon that they were talking about
was this CRISPR Cas9 in the X-Files.
Okay. And isn't it interesting that
the
vertical farming or farms are
involved in developing this technology.
So, AeroFarms also worked on an
NIH-sponsored
trial to produce proteins
for the COVID jabs. That's a very
complex, convoluted, intertwined
activity going on here, right?
So, let's just go back to basics.
This is what the industry is doing.
And there were mega companies involved
right from the begin beginning, whether
you call them Monsanto,
that has been bought over by Bayer,
which of course is a mega pharmaceutical
company as well. These are giant giant
corporations. We're not talking
billions, we're talking trillions.
And they control all of these things.
Of course, companies like Monsanto also
produced uh Roundup Ready genetic
manipulation,
so that you can spray Roundup. They've
lost numerous court cases now, by the
way,
where there have been claims because the
Roundup causes cancer.
Now, we've spoken about uh farming quite
a lot
in in the course of our series.
And we ask ourselves the question, how
does God farm?
What are the most productive
ecosystems
known to man
on Earth?
The rainforests. The rainforests. Okay.
Now, who plows the rainforest? Nobody.
Nobody plows the rainforest. But they're
the most productive ecosystems
that you have.
In actual fact, the soil
is pretty poor.
Why? Because everything is in the plants
and being circulated in a perfect cycle
of growth, decomposition,
cycling it around and around,
and you have the best farmers in the
soil, all the microorganisms,
the macroorganisms, the earthworms, the
nematodes, and they're all playing their
important little parts
parts, and you have the fungi,
and they're all
contributing to the activity.
That is the best farming method that you
can possibly have, and it's totally
organic.
There's no fertilizer that has to be
added, none whatsoever,
and it is a perfectly self-contained
system.
And what the micro organism organisms
produce, and what the earthworms
produce, and what the macroorganisms
produce, and what the fungi produce,
all contributes to the health of the
plants.
Right? Mhm.
Now, that's the system that God put into
place. And then man came along and
decided, "No, we're not going to do
that.
We're going to strip everything.
We're going to fertilize, whereby we
kill all the microorganisms, and we also
destroy the macroorganisms, and we're
going to feed the plants.
And then we'll feed the nations." Now,
what does a plant need to grow? We've
discussed this many times.
Five or six minerals will make the plant
look good, but be nutritionally totally
deficient.
So, uh if you have the basic minerals
like phosphorus and nitrogen and
potassium,
et cetera, in the soil, calcium of
course,
uh then the plant can actually produce
lush green. It's very susceptible to
disease
and to uh
insects. Mhm. So, you better spray it a
lot in order to curtail that, right?
And then you use organophosphates, which
are
very harmful to humanity,
and you start a system of monoculture.
And you concentrate on one thing. Now,
did God, when he created Adam and Eve
and put them in the garden, give them
monoculture? Did they have only one
plant from which they had to survive?
No, it was a plethora of plants. Okay.
So, it was
it was a multiple system. It had
everything. It had grains, it had
legumes, it had seed-bearing plants, it
had fruit trees, it had everything,
right?
So, that's the way God designed it.
Now,
today
we have two kinds of farming. You have
organic farming,
and you have this kind of farming that
we're talking about.
This one is absolutely controlled.
What you put in
is determined by the industry.
If you get these gene-manipulated
plants, or even if you get F1 generation
plants, can you use that seed to
propagate the next generation? No, it's
like the presumptuous victory. It's not
going to bear fruit. That's very well
put, Martin.
That's exactly what it's going to be
like.
So, the real kind of farming that God
instituted
uh
is one where you nurture the plants by
feeding the soil,
not by feeding the plant.
The soil has to feed the plant. In order
to do that, you must have the
microorganisms and the macroorganisms
to break down the soils by their
activity. So, you need organic matter in
the soil. That's compost and uh
the leaf material that falls down, and
that creates the environment of
digesting that, provides the acids,
which leads the minerals out of the out
of the soil itself, and the plant takes
up the minerals, and so the cycle
continues. That's how
God designed it.
And he gave us
heirloom seeds. Mhm.
In other words, that which they
inherited from their parents, heirloom.
So, each seed can propagate the next
generation, the next generation, and the
next generation.
And the types of fruits that you get,
let's take anything, let's take um
tomatoes.
In England, you would call them
tomatoes. Yes, and some will argue that
that's not a fruit, it's a vegetable.
Yes, some will argue that. And the
Americans will say, "Then why don't you
say potato?"
But be that as it may,
do you have variety in heirloom seeds?
Enormous variety.
What kind of uh
tomato can you get? You can get a tiny
little one, you can get a yellow one,
you can get a red one, you can get a
black one, you can get a green one, you
can get all kinds of varieties.
Plus, you get
uh
huge tomatoes,
like rainbow and oxtail tomatoes.
And they are amazing when it comes to
flavor.
But they're not very good for the market
because they squash easily, so you need
something that is not too large,
something that's not odd-shaped,
something that has firm structure,
and that's the way you want it to be.
And so, you manipulate it, even
genetically, to get exactly what you
want.
And you have this flavorless thing that
looks quite good,
but compared to heirloom,
it tastes like
a windowpane.
That's true, and uh if you bite into
your sandwich
on the other one, the whole sandwich
disintegrates when you bite through it.
When one of these, you bite through it,
it's as soft as Correct.
a knife through
vegan butter.
All right, my bottom line is this.
Uh
the heirloom seed industry
compared to the other seed industry is
minuscule.
Yeah.
Right?
It's absolutely minuscule. And it is
often trampled upon and uh denigrated,
and they try to get rid of it. My advice
to anyone is
get heirloom seeds,
store them, put them in the
refrigerator, if necessary, freeze them,
but get heirloom seeds so that we do not
become dependent on these uh
organizations cuz they want to control
you.
Now, that is not a conspiracy.
Yeah. The Bible says they want to
control you.
And if you do some research,
this is easy to see who controls what.
Correct.
So, here's another article. The food
industry is already monopolized by 10
companies, the majority of which include
Vanguard and BlackRock as top
shareholders.
So, here are all these companies.
See, there are many listed over here.
But in the center,
you have Nestlé,
Coca-Cola,
Mars, Kellogg,
uh PepsiCo, all of these companies. And
of course, BlackRock is one of that con-
that owns most of those again.
And people think that that's it.
But I feel there's something missing in
the middle here
because who controls these?
And if you do a little bit of research,
you will come to the conclusion that the
Knights of Malta Yes. control them. And
who do they swear allegiance to, Martin?
To the Pope.
Aha. And are our political entities,
like presidents, also part of the
Knights of Malta? We've shown numerous
times
how all of these go to the Vatican. Yes.
For their instructions. And uh when it
comes to the Knights of Malta, are they
independent or the do they associate
with the Jesuits? Definitely. They
control
So, the Jesuits are more into the
teaching and the philosophy and the
political aspects. These guys are
interested in the market economy. Do we
read about that in Revelation chapter 18
as to who controls the markets?
Don't they weep and wail when Babylon
falls? Why would they weep and wail?
Because
Because all their riches are suddenly
gone. How can their riches be gone if
they are self-contained?
They wouldn't care two hoots about what
happens to the next guy, right? They
just buy them up. Yeah, they'll just
trample on them.
But no. No, they weep and wail.
Martin, people must understand prophecy
to understand where this go is going.
But this means control. That's
All right. Now, if we were sinister,
is it possible that these mega
companies, controlled by these sinister
individuals,
could actually manipulate the food that
they present to you in such a way that
they might put something into your body
that you might not ordinarily want in
there? Mhm.
I
Definitely, it's part of the their whole
scheme because they don't a moral
compass.
Perhaps they do, but it's warped. Yeah.
It's It will be for their benefit. Yes,
the dragon gives them their power and
great authority, and he's not a friend
of humanity.
Okay.
Martin, this is very very very
important. Uh
are there news
uh outlets which tell you that some of
the foods and processed foods that you
buy
uh contain things like graphene oxide,
for example? Yeah.
Is that correct?
Mhm.
And uh you know, I myself have taken a
magnet to see
if there are things in there. We've
spoken about that sort of thing.
And there are very strange things
happening, but even if you leave that
out, which might be considered
conspiratorial,
uh if you take the the additives, the E
list that is in there,
does everybody have a little booklet to
show them what the E symbols actually
stand for? No. Some of them might be
good because they might just stand for
vitamin E or something,
but some of them are very very sinister.
TBHQ, what's a petrochemical waste doing
in your food? Do you want to eat it? I
don't think you you can almost not find
a product these days that don't have it
in. So, I cannot buy any of those
products. I ignore them all. So, any of
the cereals that you see or or the
crisps. Anything. They have it in. And
if it says there, I don't buy it.
But there are other components, if you
do a study of what they actually do,
they might enhance the crispness and the
longevity of the product,
but they are highly deleterious to
humanity. Why they are even permitted is
unbelievable.
So, any of these mega companies,
Martin, we must go back
to original diets. You have to. You see,
that's exactly where you come in now.
Now you got graphs showing that in the
past 100 years
that with as soon as uh more
carbohydrates and all of this has been
consumed, that's where the increase in
cancer and all of that started.
But what about all this nonsense that
you've just spoken of that's been
implemented in food? Yes. Why don't they
then take that into consideration?
Here's another question. Has humanity
become dependent upon these companies?
You Nobody is
um
looking after themselves anymore. You
are totally dependent on
All right. Did we have a major infant
food catastrophe in the world? And were
the mothers despairing because they
didn't know what to feed their children?
Now, just throw yourself back into the
days of Abraham.
Did Abraham have this kind of
supermarket with these processed foods
available to him to feed his infants?
No, but you don't have to go that far
back. I'm just
just contemplating here.
Just go back to 300 years ago. No, go
back 100 years ago. All right, did they
have this? Now, they'll say, "Well, the
people were malnourished, they were
this, that, and the other."
Uh Abraham still looked more like the
angelic host than than anything else,
so.
They knew how to feed themselves.
We have to learn how to feed ourselves.
And we have to become whole food
experts.
Because not only is it uh a fact that
the products that they put into the food
are harmful for you,
if you want to become a little bit more
conspiratorial,
there might even be a planned attack on
humanity.
That's what they said in the X-Files,
didn't they? That's it. That's where I
think it's will be good for people to
open their eyes and look at it. All
right. So, even if that is all
conspiratorial in order to move you
Hegelian dialectically
into a particular direction,
just taking the additives that they add
to food should be enough to tell you we
have to have a different lifestyle.
So, Bill Gates insists that droughts and
climate change is destroying our ability
to farm
and that the future will consist of
populations moving into metropolitan
cities where indoor vertical farming is
necessary to feed people. Fortunately,
we have people like Bill Gates who knows
everything, so we can dispense with
Google and encyclopedias.
We just ask him what should be done and
that should be fine, right? You don't
You forget that we actually can thank
Bill Gates that for Google because if he
didn't bring
the whole computer to us,
we didn't we wouldn't have been able to
use Google. Okay, but where's the flaw?
He's saying move into the metropolitan
cities and we will feed you what we want
to feed you.
Uh I have information
that God wants the exact opposite. Get
out and get back to a natural lifestyle.
So, this is uh a bundle being tied
together for the fire, moving in one
direction and God wants us to move in
the opposite direction.
And so, you can also take if the devil
who sits behind this wants you to move
back into the cities, he's going to make
it hard to move to move out. So, I'm
actually very grateful to people like
Bill Gates. They make it very easy for
me to determine what not to do.
But they can also have some deception in
it. Ah, that is true because sometimes
they will say exactly what we would say
we should do,
but there's a twist in the tail and we
mustn't forget that. That's exactly.
Because when they say, for example, we
have to go vegetarian
or vegan. Or vegan, it is a manipulated
food source that they are talking about
and not a whole food natural product.
That is so important.
That's very important.
Because now everybody will say, "Okay,
so they say we must become vegan." So,
no no no, we must do exactly the
opposite. We must only eat meat. But
they control the meat as well. They
control them both because why would they
build these mega companies to to process
all that beef? Do you think you're
eating clean meat?
I think they have to look at some of
your presentations from even years back.
Yes, let's look at some of these things.
If this is the case,
why has he acquired 2
142,000
acres of farmland over the past decade
while simultaneously investing in indoor
vertical farming?
Who gets to sit at the table with
healthy products served by Gates while
the rest of the population
eats gene-edited produce from lockdown
facilities delivered to their local
grocery stores and accessed only through
a digital ID?
You know, be that as it may,
bottom line is we will control the food
source.
And we will control who has access to
it.
That's biblical. That is where it's
headed.
Well, let's continue with this article.
It is quite comprehensive.
Well over a dozen major food processing
and meat plants have coincidentally gone
up in flames in the past several months.
Now, whether these are
self-destructed
or whether they are sabotaged or whether
that is natural is neither here nor
there. What is the outcome?
That's what we're looking at.
Since the start of 2022,
over a dozen major food processing and
fertilizer plants have gone up in
flames, exploded, or been struck by a
plane crash in Arizona, Kansas,
California, Illinois, Indiana, Kansas,
and Louisiana, Maine, New Hampshire,
North Carolina, Oregon, Texas,
Washington, and Wisconsin. Is that
coincidence, Martin?
Well, that
according to the narrative, yes. Have
the fact-checkers given us any
information? That would be very useful.
They have. They've
If you put in I've mentioned this before
um
food
food processing plant disasters, just
those words into
our friend Google,
the first page is fact-check.
Oh. Okay. Who controls fact-checkers?
Now, Martin, here are some of the
pictures to corroborate these statements
and uh
you know, airplanes flying into
buildings, that's quite a common
occurrence in the last couple of
decades.
So, the USDA and the FDA have already
approved lab-grown meat, genetically
modified cattle, and are funding the
globalists to research and develop
cellular agriculture as well as indoor
growers and genetic companies while they
slack on regulations for gene-edited
produce.
Uh God's people should stay as far away
as what from these? The east from the
west. I think so.
Sure, the idea of indoor vertical
farming could be a great avenue for
those with little land,
those who live in harsher climates, and
everyone who wants food security while
these agendas against humanity continue
to roll out.
But wouldn't it make more sense for
communities to be doing this to meet
their own needs rather than relying on a
digital ID to get access to a controlled
food industry?
The nutritional value from LED versus
the sun
likely removes some of the nutrients in
the produce, but if faced with having
difficulty accessing food or not
desiring gene-edited food,
it might be a good idea.
All right, people Martin, there might be
people that don't like this and move
away from this system, but the majority
of humanity
will have no choice.
No. Right?
So,
uh who will become the target of these
moguls if they want total control?
God's people who are moving away from
this.
Okay. So,
do we have an enemy?
Yes.
All right. Is the enemy, excuse that I
used the name, Bill Gates? No. No, he's
a pawn in the game.
They want you to think
They want me to think he's the enemy.
And they're really trying very hard to
make him the enemy, right?
Just like the Georgia Guidestones. They
said reduce the population to 500
million. So, the obvious solution is to
Blow it up. Blow them up. That's going
to
end it all. Get rid of the problem.
Whereas vertical farming is brilliant in
many ways and could be beneficial on a
smaller scale in communities,
the fact that this is the global agenda
to remove farms and control all produce
by the globalists themselves
makes it incredibly concerning.
Are they planting a seed in your mind
here? Yeah, obviously you can see this
article is written
by
the
somebody that has chosen a side. All
right. Now, here's another question.
Mega farms and places like this, is
there a movement in the world to
disinherit people from these farms? Yes.
Now, and just to put it out there, if
the farms have been disinherited, what
happens to the farms? Are they then
uh
fur
uh used or do they lie dormant? They
normally lie dormant or
they just go back to desert wasteland.
Mhm.
Now, be that as it may, what does the
spirit of prophecy tell us?
We must move into the country where we
can buy a small piece of land where we
can grow our own vegetables. That
doesn't sound like going into mega
farming to me.
not at all. So, it's not bad advice
considering what the plans are here.
So, God is not to be left out of this
equation. No.
But it's interesting to see where we are
heading.
Imagine in the not-too-distant future
going for a drive in the countryside in
your mandated electrical vehicle and
observing dried-up farmland replaced by
giant turbines.
It's a very dystopian image that no one
wants to experience.
So, here again, there is
an element of fear-mongering,
conspiratorial
ideas being placed in the minds of men,
but nevertheless,
the bottom line is there is a move to
control the food supply.
what's important. We That's why we
discuss this.
You We're not going to get an article
out there
that is going to see it the way that the
Bible explains it.
Most of the times, the person that
writes the article would have would have
chosen a side. All right. So, they are
biased in their thinking. We must be
very careful
that we don't become biased in our
thinking. Remember that when QAnon was
the big hype in the world,
uh we warned that this is part of the
Hegelian dialectic. Be careful. Don't
jump onto a bandwagon because you're
looking for a savior. Exactly. The
bottom line, Martin, is there is no
earthly savior. Forget it. It's not
going to happen.
We're going to go to chaos. We're going
to go to famine. We're going to go to
destruction.
And there is a savior, but you have to
choose the right one. Exactly.
Now, here's an interesting graph as to
what the war in the Ukraine is doing in
terms of fueling the food crisis.
Run us through these graphs, Martin.
Well, the red line is food oils.
And how important is that in everyday
cooking
for the majority of the world's
population? So, these are the price
increases, right? So, a price increase
is always an indication of availability.
Mhm.
Because if availability drops, prices
increase.
So, this shows that there is a massive
increase in terms of oil prices.
137%.
All right. What about the yellow line?
Yellow line is cereals.
So, they've gone up. This is a staple
food.
Yeah.
So, now it becomes a little bit more
serious. It's not as serious as the the
luxury, the oils,
but it's quite serious. And the black
one?
The food price index. All right. So,
generally, everything is going up. Food
is becoming more expensive.
60%. That's That's a lot.
In the past
Now, we're not talking about we're not
talking about fossil fuels here. We're
talking about food, right?
Yeah.
And this is all blamed on the war in
Ukraine. Yes. What about this purple
line here?
That's dairy.
So, dairy is on the increase.
And then you've got meat and sugar.
So, basically, everything is going up
and the most important ones as far as
I'm concerned is the first three here,
which all have an upward trend.
So, that's the oil price,
the grain price, and the food index
price.
So, things are becoming tighter. Yeah.
And there is someone to blame.
Exactly. They
They've always got someone. There's
always someone to blame.
And they're always looking at the wrong
guy.
The Economist: Costly food and energy
are fostering global unrest.
So, when you have a food crisis or when
you have an energy crisis, then you have
unrest. Does that suit the purposes of
the enemy? They love chaos.
Because out of that, they can get their
synthesis. Their order. Their order.
Ordo ab chao.
"So, money no longer had any value in
Istanbul," laments the narrator of My
Name Is Red, a novel by Orhan Pamuk, set
in the 16th century. Galloping inflation
afflicts Turkey again today. Officially,
it is 73%,
but everyone suspects that it's higher.
So, here is a Nobel laureate who is
talking about these things and
is lamenting the fact
that we are seeing these things
happening in the world. Now, not only
Turkey. Take Sri Lanka, for example.
Chaos. Or take inflation in the United
States of America.
And isn't it interesting that the
currency that is gaining in strength
through all of this is the ruble?
The ruble.
Isn't that ironic?
Okay. So, are we heading for a crisis?
Oh, it's inevitable.
And now, here's a graph that we also
find in The Economist, which is a very
reputable source.
Uh I don't know what we can call
reputable these days any anymore, but
let's say it's these were reputable
sources.
Well, well, you can almost state that
this is coming from the organizers or
the
it's it's
reputable because
they might be part of the whole system.
Okay.
So, it talks about the possibility of
outbreaks of unrest over the next 12
months from June 2022
to the next 12 months.
And you can see the barometer over here.
Very high are the red ones, and then
uh that's 100%, 75, 50, 25, 0,
and minus.
And what do we find? Well, here we have
the red countries, and we can see where
they are. Some of them are, of course,
in Africa.
Uh one or two here in South America.
Egypt.
Okay. So, the probability of unrest uh
up to about 50% or all these darker
areas. Martin, it looks like our country
is in for a
for a roller coaster ride.
We've seen that in the last week. Yes,
we just had riots again yesterday And
that's because of energy.
And that's an energy riot.
Now, it's interesting that they've left
the United States,
Canada, Australia,
and some of these countries here in the
East and Europe, they've left them out
of this picture Mhm.
because of apparent insufficient data.
Now, Martin, when you look at the news,
where do you read about unrest?
Europe. Isn't it in Europe and the
United States?
Didn't all the farmers in
the Netherlands now go on the rampage
and the supermarkets are empty because
they're being marginalized by government
rules? Mhm.
Now, why are they making rules to
marginalize farmers?
For climate change.
Now, when I was young, Martin,
we
there was a time when I was young.
Uh farmers were the ones that were
protected and that were, you know,
helped by governments. Now, it seems
that the opposite is true. Mhm.
And also in France, you have riots by
the farmers. So, you know, insufficient
data is probably a bit tongue-in-cheek.
But the experts that give us this
information are, of course, the IMF, the
World Bank,
all of these mega mega organizations.
So, can we expect unrest? No.
Definitely.
So, what does the World Economic Forum
have to tell us about this? So, where do
chief economists expect high inflation
and high food insecurity? Tough times
ahead for the global economy, say
experts.
There are two aspects here, Martin.
You have the expectation of high
inflation,
and then you have the expectation of
food insecurity.
So, for the United States, they say high
inflation, 96% probability, but zero
percent food insecurity. Do you believe
that?
No. I don't believe that at all. How
many of the food packaging companies and
have been destroyed in the United
States?
what just happened with the baby food
formula? Oh.
A lots of insecurities.
Maybe what they know that they're not
saying here is that there won't really
be a food insecurity, there will just be
an insecurity of accessing the food.
That's it. Control. Control.
Now, where
in which
country do we read that the control will
become Is that in the Bible? Exactly.
It's in Revelation chapter 13, right? In
the Protestant bastion,
which has supposedly
freed itself from the shackles and
chains of the Middle Ages.
They will put those shackles and chains
on willingly.
What makes people willing to put on
shackles and chains?
If you don't have food. Food.
Doesn't that scenario
put you right back in Egypt with Joseph?
That's where we're heading.
That's where we're heading. And we're
going to go to what the Pope has to say
about that, but we'll leave that for a
moment.
Then South America, food, well, there's
more insecurity there. When it comes to
Africa, it looks absolutely disastrous.
Inflation as well as food insecurity.
And when we go to the East, well, all of
these first world countries,
they don't seem to be too worried about
food, but I have some news for them.
Yeah.
I think the Bible
is telling us that this food insecurity
will be international.
I agree with you, but it's also
interesting that, as we've mentioned now
with the United States,
those other countries, it's almost as
even the countries where there's more
control over the food, they don't have
in food security problems. All right. If
you look at Africa,
they don't have these mega facilities
like we've we've read in the previous
article.
So, nobody is growing or will be able to
supply the food. They are mostly growing
their own food.
Yes, and if you haven't not prepared
yourself
if you don't have seed
if you're not ready to take care of
yourself, there can be serious issues in
Africa.
So, either way whatever way we look at
it
even if you look at
Africa for example, they said previously
we would have a lot of unrest.
But what if the north has a lot of war?
That would be interesting.
So, here's another article. Another food
processing plant shutters operations
adding to the long list of closures.
So, George's Prepared Foods announced
its chicken processing plant in the
small town of Caribou
would be shuttering operations by the
end of the summer. The announcement of
the closure pushed up the number of
closed US food processing plants over
the last year to 100.
Meanwhile in London, Ontario, Aspire
Food Groups recently announced that its
new insect production facility
would produce 9,000 metric tons of
crickets yearly for human and pet
consumption across North America
according to Canadian manufacturing.
What now are you into crickets?
No, thanks.
Thank God I'm not into cricket. I'll
rather plant vegetables. Yes. And then
eat that.
So, Martin as we said last time, make
sure you have a staple in the ground.
A potato, a sweet potato
uh
a carrot
and have those staples in the ground.
Have a couple of grains stored and etc.
So, as a reminder the World Economic
Forum technocrats urged people weeks ago
to ditch meat for climate beneficial
foods such as seaweed, algae, and cacti.
Part of the New World Order is to reset
the global economy and re-engineer what
people eat. Bottom line is they want to
get rid of private farming. Yes.
Get rid of it, have industry farming and
then go into processed foods with
insects and uh
all kinds of things and alternative meat
products
or genetically grown meat products in a
petri dish.
Now, is any of that natural? No. No.
Now, when they say uh
that we must have alternatives to meat
products
then they're talking about highly
processed foods. Not natural foods.
Yes, they're talking about the products
that they produce.
Do you know what's in them? No. No. But
the same, you don't know what's in the
meat and all the other things that they
also produce for you.
Exactly. So
the bottom line is we should move away
from processed foods. Eat plainly. Eat
naturally. Eat whole foods. Is this
massive drive as we look at this
towards protein?
Protein is what you need.
You only need about 8 g of protein per
kilogram body mass.
Which means that the average person
needs about
60 to 80 g of protein per day.
The body is designed for carbohydrates.
Now, the media has made the carbohydrate
the enemy of humanity. That's it. Not
even the media, the scientists and
doctors.
Well, the scientists do not know
what the body is designed for.
The building blocks
are the proteins. They're the building
blocks. They're the machinery. They're
the the enzymes that run things. They
are your musculature. They are all of
those things.
That's your protein. But once you are
established
and you are an adult, you only need 8 g
for maintenance of what breaks down etc.
If you are an infant or a child that is
growing rapidly instead of 8 g, you
might need 10 g. But then your body
weight is less.
Is less. So, again it's a very small
amount of protein that you actually
require.
The fuel that runs the body is
carbohydrate.
And the brain
exclusively
runs on carbohydrate. Its main
infrastructure is made not from protein
but from fats.
So, again you have to have all of these
nutrients in your lifestyle.
Now, why has carbohydrate received such
a bad press? Because of those industries
That's it. that have refined it down to
the point where you have a food that
causes
blood sugar surges that causes
hypoglycemia as a consequence, all kinds
of intestinal diseases because they've
taken out the fiber.
Two kinds of fiber, soluble fiber,
insoluble fiber.
Absolutely essential for gut motility
and a healthy function is insoluble
fiber.
Absolutely essential for glucose
regulation and sugar regulation is
soluble fiber. You need them both. So,
you need unrefined
natural carbohydrates. That's what you
were designed for to eat as fuel. Now,
if you take a fruit, I give you every
fruit bearing plant. What is the highest
concentration in a fruit?
Carbohydrate or protein? Carbohydrate.
Correct. There's only about 2% protein
in a fruit. The rest is carbohydrate.
How is it packed?
With soluble fiber. Soluble fiber.
That's why you can cook jams that become
like gel. That's why when you cook oats
it becomes gooey because it has soluble
fiber. What's the function of the
soluble fiber? Glucose regulation. Sugar
regulation. You need whole foods. These
industries are the bane of society. They
have destroyed generations with their
refined products that they feed from
tiny little children all the way through
adults. That's why we have diabetes.
That's why we have secondary diseases.
That's why we have all of these things.
And then to crown it all
they throw the baby out with the
bathwater.
That's the problem. They throw out the
carbohydrate because they assume that
that is the problem. No, it's the
perverted carbohydrate that is the
problem. Exactly.
Now again, Martin when we talk about who
the moguls are that are controlling
everything
they always take you back to
these billionaires or the Rothschilds or
the Rockefellers
and they don't realize that the name
Rothschild for example is something that
derives from ancient times, rothschild,
red shield. That was the emblem of the
Roman army.
And they are actually Vatican bankers.
That's it.
So, the Rockefellers fall into that same
category. Rockefeller Foundation Reset
the Table report predicted COVID-related
food crisis 2 years before it happened.
Now, do you remember that
there was a
tremendous destruction of grain silos in
Lebanon
and they have these mega facilities in
China for example.
If they withhold that food, there's a
world food crisis.
Mhm.
So, just a few months into COVID-19
pandemic and almost 2 years before
global health officials warned of a food
shortage crisis, the Rockefeller
Foundation issued a report predicting
the crisis and offering up solutions
including shifts to online enrollment,
online purchasing of food.
Uh Martin, who controls all of those
mechanisms?
They do. Yeah, industry. Industry.
So, in a report published July 28, 2020,
Reset the Table, Meeting the Moment to
Transform the US food system
the foundation described the hunger and
nutrition crisis unlike any this country
has seen in generations.
And the authors blamed the crisis on
COVID-19.
Now, is there information out there that
claims that COVID-19
was a manipulated crisis? Mhm. There is,
right? They are saying that. Well, if
you want to reset something
That's it.
then what must you do with the old? You
must make it redundant. You must remove
it. Yeah. Is it happening?
Okay, so we must always look at the
outcomes. Mhm. And then again ask the
question, who wants it? Yes. Someone who
wants control. Just these one these
people that have a lot of money what
they already have the money. They must
be another agenda. All right, so what is
it they want to control? Mhm. They want
to control you. Yeah.
Now, who in the Bible
is the one that is pointed at as the one
who wants to control you?
Satan. Satan. And who is his agent
according to the scriptures? The beast,
the papacy. The beast.
Mhm. The papacy.
Now, who's dancing and doing his
bidding?
The second beast.
beast. All right, so we're back to the
Bible. If you don't study your Bible,
you will you will either think that
these people are the enemy or you will
think that they are the heroes that are
going to save you. Yeah. There are no
heroes
on this planet that are going to save
you.
So, the report concluded the crisis
would have to be addressed not by
strengthening food security for the most
vulnerable but by revamping the entire
food system and associated supply chain.
In other words, we would need to reset
the table.
Martin?
My Bible tells me what my food is. I
have no desire to have my diet reset.
Mhm. I've done that once. Yeah. When I
got off this worldly
diet that was destroying my health and
everybody else's in the world.
I've reset. I don't want to reset to
theirs. I will not eat cockroaches.
Yeah.
And any other gene modified No locusts,
no anything. And by the way, John the
Baptist ate locusta and not the insect.
Yeah.
So, the Rockefeller Foundation called
for this food system reset less than two
months after the World Economic Forum on
June the 3rd, 2020 revealed its vision
for the great reset. Isn't this
interesting?
They're all linking together. They're
all playing the same tune.
All right, Martin, let's have a look
what Sky News has to say about current
circumstances.
Currently, in two very different places
around the world, we are seeing what
happens when the left and the climate
cult start implementing their crackpot
schemes to save the planet.
You see, none of these net zero climate
schemes work without massively
disrupting or even destroying the lives
of the little people, small businesses,
family farms, mom and dad enterprises,
ordinary family life.
In Holland, currently, there are massive
demonstrations. You won't see them on
the news because the Dutch authorities
are literally shutting down small farms
in order to slash nitrogen oxide and
ammonia emissions by 2030.
Thousands of tractor-driving Dutch
protesters came out this week to
continue demonstrations against the
government's radical plan to cut
nitrogen nitrogen emissions by 30% to
70%
as part of their green agenda.
Completely arbitrary bureaucratic
madness.
But this is what happens when you
legislate climate targets. The little
people, the farmers, the small
businesses, they get crushed under the
wheels of the bureaucrats who believe
they are saving the planet.
Small farmers are now desperately
fighting back in Holland as they are in
Sri Lanka.
Where a different set of insane green
policies by the government there are
forcing all farms to go organic, which
has led to starvation, poverty, and
despair. And here
are the police and army literally
stopping everyday Sri Lankans from
getting any gasoline.
This is, I fear, merely a glimpse of the
dystopian world that awaits us if we
pursue the folly of bureaucratically
mandating a reduction in the energy
supplies that sustain our food supplies,
our health, and our shelter, and so much
more.
We know how labor governments in
Australia behave when they want to
enforce their rules and restrictions,
but some members of the public have a
different opinion.
Holland, Sri Lanka, Australia, hard to
tell them apart.
So, Martin, the news outlet is lamenting
the situation. Do they have a solution?
No.
There's no solution.
Well,
they also get the scenario that we have
to get we have to stand up against this.
All right, so what does that mean? That
means more civil unrest.
And that is more chaos.
So, all of these things are working
together.
Now, let's step back again Mhm. and
reiterate.
This is no time to get involved in this
battle because you're fighting the wrong
battle then. Mhm.
This is all leading towards some
something. Let's just make that very
clear again.
The Bible tells us where we're heading.
There will be a time of trouble such as
never was.
So, when you see this happening, do you
climb onto the barricade to try and stop
the time of chaos such as never was? No.
What's the point? It's predicted. It's
futile. You're wasting your breath and
you're wasting your time.
So, is this a time for introspection?
That's it.
That's where it all comes back to.
Get yourself ready. All right, what do
you take to heaven?
Do you take your food supply to heaven?
Do you take your houses to heaven? Do
you take your money in the bank? Do you
take any of these to heaven? No. What do
you take to heaven?
Only your character.
Ah. So, Martin, time for introspection.
And time to do what God said. Mhm. So,
if God says, you know,
I can
spare you some of this.
Try and get out into the country.
Some prepare the way. You know, we've
spoken about this more more than ever
before, but just to show how serious
this is.
That's it.
And then there are people, Martin,
within the church that say nothing's
happening. What's wrong with them?
And they won't probably mind if
everything is controlled.
No, they're probably quite happy.
Now, here's another interesting article
because this puts another spin on the
ball.
Everything is so computerized today
that uh
as soon as you are hacked, for example,
a whole industry can collapse.
And remember, we had a video of Klaus
Schwab where he said this was going to
happen.
Cyber attacks. Now, if they predict
cyber attacks,
have they planned cyber attacks, Martin?
What's interesting is you'll see now in
the article as well
as
just after he mentioned that these
attacks occurred. Okay. All right, so
again, you have an invisible enemy. You
have a hacker
who destroys the entire food industry.
Now, Martin, if you have your own little
garden
in your back garden and you're making
microgreens and you're planting your
little things,
uh
if somebody hacks your phone, does your
garden disintegrate? No.
Just very interesting.
So, FBI warns food and agriculture to
brace for seasonal ransomware attacks.
So, this is where they hack you
and you can't cannot go back into
production unless you pay ransom, right?
So, the Federal Bureau of Investigation
released the private industry
notification warning agriculture
cooperatives,
also known as farmers co-ops, of the
looming danger of well-timed ransomware
attacks.
The agency warns that during the
critical planting and harvesting
seasons, attacks could result in the
theft of
proprietary information and operational
disruption leading to financial losses
and even food shortages.
They did that with the oil supply as
well, right? So, they do all of these
things.
And the energy
supply.
So, there are many of these ransomware
variants. Now, who's the enemy again?
It's some vague individual that nobody
can define. You normally target Russia
or China or North Korea. They're
bringing the world to their knees.
Again, we want to reiterate
don't look in the wrong place for the
enemy. It's people have to be careful.
Because if you
put your
focus on one place, you can easily be
sidetracked.
Correct. Here's an article from Reuters.
Heat, humidity kills at least 2,000
Kansas cattle.
This was an interesting story, Martin.
Because it killed the cattle, but it
killed nothing else. No. And again, we
bring it back. Now,
climate change is also in the whole
scenario. All right. So, we've got
climate change involved. And now, this
was because of global warming and the
terrible heat. All the cattle fell over.
The horses didn't.
And the goats didn't, and the sheep
didn't, and the the cats didn't, and the
dogs didn't, and the humans didn't, but
uh the cattle did.
So, there were many questions.
So, the deaths add pain to the US cattle
industry as producers have reduced herds
due to drought and grappled with feed
costs, etc. We We don't have to read all
of this.
It just shows that there is let's use
the word a total onslaught on the food
supply. Definitely.
And it will probably go back to what
we've read in that first article
for the food control. Yes. So, let's get
the United Nations involved.
That's the next step, right?
Uh we've already relinquished our
powers, or the governments have, to the
World Health Organization in terms of of
the health issues of the world. Why not
also relinquish the food issues?
So, Secretary General warns of
unprecedented global hunger crisis with
276 million facing food insecurity
calling for export recovery and debt
relief.
So, we can go through this article and
we can discuss what they're talking
about. They're talking about fertilizer
problems, fertilizer prices that have
gone up affecting billions of people in
Asia and Africa. So, we need an entire
global economic reset.
That's it.
It all comes back to that the whole
time. And this is a sad state of affairs
because this will probably come true.
There will be millions of people
starving. So, are they playing in the
same band as the World Economic Forum?
Yeah.
Are they singing the same tune?
The whole right through. All right. So,
basically, what we've seen now is that
the world is heading for a crisis.
To summarize,
they have targeted certain groups that
are responsible.
And some of these are trying to save the
world like the
the mega moguls of the world, and some
of them are being seen as the enemies.
And then you have vague enemies like
hackers and this and that.
Irrespective, bottom line is it's going
to crash.
That's it.
Let's go to the heart of the matter.
Now,
remember the Tony Palmer situation where
Tony Palmer, who is now deceased, Yeah.
claimed that Protestantism was over, the
protest was over. He was actually
speaking in Kenneth Copeland's church.
Correct. And they had this interview
with the Pope, who was so happy
that the Reformation was over.
But it stretched more much further than
that. It embraced the whole global
community.
And after this time, of course, he
brought out his documents on fraternity.
Yeah.
And so, he had this fraternity idea.
And anticipating
a crisis,
we have to meet our brother in Egypt and
give him bread. Let's listen.
Martin, that sounds like a very
emotional
speech.
And there are a few things that are very
concerning.
Because the unity that he is talking
about here
is not a unity in truth.
It's separated people coming together
on the basis of compromise. Yeah.
He said the separation was sin.
Well, when truth is involved, separation
sometimes becomes necessary. Even war
becomes necessary.
Because
truth cannot be compromised.
For 500 years, they warred against
Protestantism.
They declared Protestantism over.
And they have to create a crisis
that will unite humanity.
That's exactly what he And he's using a
bread crisis
in order to bring humanity together.
So, that we all meet as brothers and
sisters, fraternity.
There's just one problem.
That is a fraternity
outside of the biblical
directive. Yes, because the center of
the Bible has to be
set aside. Yes, he called the separation
sin.
But the Bible identifies his system as
the man of sin.
So, now we have a choice.
And I believe that the crises that are
coming
are going to do precisely what the Pope
said.
And anybody
who does not want to be part of that
system, doesn't want to be part of that
fraternity,
will be targeted.
Is everything in place so that that one
will not be able to buy or sell? That's
it. Is everything in place so that he
can be disenfranchised
and marginalized?
Is everything in place? Is there enough
anger in the world that they might be
classified as the pariah to be destroyed
from the face of the earth?
We are heading for that
clash.
Let's pray.
Heavenly Father,
what a time we are living in.
And what a clever game is being played
out there.
Unfortunately, this clever game is at
the expense of human lives and will
cause great human suffering.
But I pray that it will direct our minds
and our thoughts to the scriptures
that we might make
right choices
in order to be in the right camp
when the final crisis
hits us.
Help us to this end in Jesus' name.
Amen. Amen.